[Música]
salud en directo América de France 24
marinas ardiña está con nosotros en el
estudio Marina bienvenida muy buena
mañana de viernes ya vamos a finalizar
esta semana y vamos a hablar de una
enfermedad invisibilizada durante mucho
tiempo décadas y también carente de
investigación Marina precisamente porque
es una dolencia que afecta a las mujeres
de todo el mundo y vamos a hablar de la
endometriosis De qué trata Buenos días
Raúl efectivamente la endometriosis es
una enfermedad que ha estado
tradicionalmente invisibilizada y
silenciada porque precisamente afecta
solo a mujeres y esto ha llevado a que
haya una falta de investigación y no hay
hoy en día no tenemos un tratamiento
Pese a que llevan décadas padeciendo
esta enfermedad las mujeres consiste en
la aparición y crecimiento de tejido que
tapiza el interior del útero y que
aparece fuera de el sistema del útero
Como por ejemplo en el falopio en las
tropas de falopio perdón en los ovarios
en la vejiga y en otras zonas de la
pelvis provocando fuertes dolores
durante menstruación por ejemplo
dismenorrea fuertes sangrados y
precisamente para hablar de este tema y
para darle visibilidad tenemos con
nosotras a Luz Marina araque ella es
fundadora de la asociación colombiana de
endometriosis e infertilidad Muchas
gracias por estar en France 24 Luz
Marina lo primero que quería preguntarte
cuéntanos Qué es la endometriosis y Cómo
podemos detectarla Qué síntomas son los
más recurrentes
Buenos días Muchas gracias por la
invitación la endometriosis es una
enfermedad Crónica incapacitante que
afecta a una de cada 10 mujeres y que se
presenta con diferentes síntomas el
principal es ese dolor fuerte
incapacitante durante la menstruación un
dolor que para muchas no les permite
levantarse de la cama hacer esas
actividades cotidianas también
menstruaciones irregulares
menstruaciones prolongadas
menstruaciones abundantes y otros
problemas a nivel de sistema digestivo
Incluso el sistema inmunológico es una
enfermedad catalogada Como enigmática y
que ya no es vista como ginecológica
sino multisistémica por todo lo que
conlleva en la salud de quien la padecen
Luz Marina efectivamente como dices es
una enfermedad que afecta a 190 millones
de personas en todo el mundo Según la
OMS por ejemplo también la fundación
mundial de investigación de
endometriosis dice que las mujeres con
esta condición tienen un 38% menos de
productividad en su cotidianidad en sus
actividades diarias Sabiendo esto por
qué hay tanta invisibilidad porque no
hay investigación en la ciencia también
si está ligado con una ciencia
patriarcal que durante décadas que ha
olvidado las enfermedades que afectan
exclusivamente a las mujeres y Y qué
cómo vamos a encontrar una solución a
esto
efectivamente hay poca investigación en
cuanto a las patologías uterinas y sobre
todo la endometriosis es una enfermedad
no solo
indivisibilizada sino también
infradiagnosticada y que además al ser
solo padecida por mujeres se puede decir
que hay un sesgo un sesgo sexual en la
en la ciencia en la medicina en la
investigación pocas mujeres científicas
muy poca investigación en torno a la
enfermedad desde mi punto de vista
personal siempre pensado que si la
endometriosis la sufrieran los hombres
si los hombres tuvieran útero Y
menstruaran seguramente ya habría una
cura para la enfermedad
lamentables no que pues se tenga que
pasar eso para poder avanzar en la
ciencia Luz Marina la saludo Gracias por
estar con nosotros y muy buena mañana de
viernes realizarse También una
laparoscopia de geografía ayudan a
detectarla no pero sin embargo no es
suficiente muchas veces se normaliza
también este dolor Qué consecuencias
pueden tener para las si no se detecta
esta dolencia
en promedio la endometriosis se
diagnostica entre 8 y 10 años se toma
entre ocho y diez años en una mujer en
recibir ese diagnóstico certero eso es
mucho tiempo y la enfermedad avance a
veces de manera silenciosa es una
enfermedad progresiva entonces pues sí
necesitamos que haya no solamente
políticas públicas sino que también haya
protocolos específicos ese paso a seguir
esa ruta de manejo para que se
diagnostique de manera oportuna y de
esta manera no afecte tanto la calidad
de vida de la persona que la padece
porque no solamente es a nivel físico
también a nivel emocional en las
relaciones de pareja con el entorno a
nivel laboral a nivel económico es una
enfermedad compleja que afecta a la
mujer en todo sentido
Luz Marina también sabemos que se siguen
usando terapias con hormonas para que
las mujeres puedan convivir con esta
enfermedad en otros casos más graves
puede llegar hasta la histerectomía que
es la extracción del útero que
estrategias tienen las mujeres para
convivir con la enfermedad para tratarla
y también un poquito del lado de la
medicina menos occidental o menos
tradicional
de esta es una problemática a nivel
mundial y de hecho las mujeres con
endometriosis son tratadas de la misma
forma desde hace 20 25 años que es la
terapia convencional la terapia hormonal
y el procedimiento quirúrgico y se
limita solamente a eso desde la medicina
alopática desde la medicina funcional
alternativa ya hay otras opciones
terapéuticas que permiten no solamente
controlar los síntomas sino preservar la
fertilidad y recuperar la calidad de
vida y eso es parte de lo que promovemos
desde la asociación Y es que las
pacientes conozcan otras opciones otras
herramientas terapias complementarias
alternativas que pueden ayudarles a
vivir con esta enfermedad que no tiene
cura que es Crónica y las acompaña
durante muchos años precisamente de los
Marina desde su organización ayudan a
esas mujeres y a que a que recurran allí
si están sintiendo estos síntomas
también para acompañarlas puesto que
como decimos es una enfermedad muy
silenciada y pueden recurrir a esta
asociación colombiana de endometriosis e
infertilidad en el caso Colombia Luz
Marina le agradecemos por estar con
nosotros esta mañana de viernes en
directo América de Francia 24 y marina
también gracias como siempre por
acompañarnos gracias
[Música]